what you're looking at is a population
pyramid for the european union
it shows the percentage of the
population at different stages of life
the percentage of people within the
retirement bracket the people that are
of working age that support the elderly
population through their taxes and the
youngest ranging from late 20s to
teenagers and children
a population pyramid is one of the most
robust visuals for understanding society
because it's one of the clearest for
identifying a particular stage of
development in a country
this pyramid shows that europe's
fertility rate is declining the share of
europe's population that is old is
increasing and the share of the
population that is young is declining
and i think it needs to be abundantly
clear to people why continued quick
decline in fertility rates is a problem
and why it's a particular problem for
europe
societies move through demographic
stages
stage one is when death and birth rates
are both high
pre-industrialization this was the
reality for most of human society
throughout history
stage two is when death rates begin to
fall but birth rates remain high general
standards of living improve which
reduces the death rates but high
fertility still seems economically
useful the more children the more
potential providers when you're older
stage three is when birth rates also
begin to play catch-up this is usually
the result of children having a lower
benefit than they used to and
improvements in women's position in
society reducing the demand for them to
bear children where europe and the rest
of the developed world are is around
stage four death rates are low and birth
rates are also low and around one half
of the world's population lives in
countries below the fertility rate that
would keep their populations constant
europe has a 1.53 fertility rate and
without including migration europe would
be experiencing a population decline
what will come after stage 4 is unclear
death rates will probably stay low what
will happen to fertility is something we
still need to figure out
some say it will increase back to around
2.1 the replacement fertility while
others paint a bleaker picture that
birth rates will continue to decline
the logic is relatively simple
old people cost money and europe is
going to have a lot of them the key
measure here to understand is the old
age dependency ratio the amount of
working age people that support a single
elderly person
most european state pension systems have
a large part coming from a pay-as-you-go
system which means the retirement
benefits of the current retirees are
being financed by the people who are
currently working with the expectation
that future generations will finance you
when you're older over the next couple
of decades as the amount of old people
increases in europe and the amount of
young people reduce the dependency ratio
will push pension expenditures to
increase
for every person in the eu older than 65
years old in 2019 there were almost
three people aged between 20 and 64. by
2040 this ratio would fall to just two
decreasing further to 1.7 people of
working age for every person older than
65 years old in 2070.
old people carry costs much like
incredibly overweight people do you have
a pool of insurance money that is spent
when a person requires medical
assistance
increase the amount of people in that
pool that have a higher likelihood to
need medical assistance and you can
expect the insurance money to need to
rise in turn what makes this situation
more uncomfortable is that the stage of
future developments in health technology
is relatively uncertain if we were to
just account for the age increases we
can expect public health expenditure in
the eu to grow from 6.6 of gdp to 7.7
however if we saw an increasing life
expectancy with little to no gains in
health status for the old we could
imagine it becoming even more expensive
people matter because people produce and
people at different stages of their life
produce in different amounts although it
might be potentially a taboo topic a
declining share of the population that
is young may put more pressure on the
relevancy of europe and this video i can
assure you will not be the only place
you'll see making this argument
europe is the oldest continent on
average and its share of global gdp is
declining
there really aren't any perfect
solutions to this problem you can make
older generations work longer boost
migration to increase the labor force
and incentivize europeans to have more
children but each of these solutions
comes with their own set of difficulties
in 2019 macomb tried to raise the
pension age from 62 to 64.
however when mccomb took actions to
increase the retirement age which would
have reduced the burden on the taxable
class in the future this wasn't taken
lightly
[Applause]
another potential solution that's much
less controversial is migration need
more people that can support the elderly
population just bring in more workers
but there's a trade-off here and there
will probably not be enough migration to
make a serious enough dent in the
trajectory towards an aging european
society
also the impacts of migrants is
relatively unknown it's not that
migrants wouldn't have any impact on the
burden of social programs but in the
same way that improving health
technology is something that we can't
exactly predict the marginal benefits of
a specific migrant and their associated
impact on the tax base is also
relatively unknown
in addition arguing about whether
migrants should or should not be
encouraged to enter the european union
is also a relatively useless discussion
because europe might not even be in a
position where they can get enough
migrants to make a noticeable impact on
the old age dependency ratio in the
first place
there are other countries out there that
are also facing the same problems and
they will also be in the market for
labor force that can boost the overall
tax base and reduce a deficit that's
also why it should be of no surprise
that the eu is reforming their migration
policies in order to attract more highly
skilled workers through making things
like their blue card initiative which is
basically european green card more
generous
europeans also intimately understand
that increasing support for larger
inflows of migrants is probably
politically infeasible and could
legitimize critiques by the european
electorate who are concerned that
they've delegated too much authority to
an institution that removes their
ability of choosing who they want to
come into their country or not
higher shares of older populations are
associated with anti-eu votes and
although the literature has been mixed
on this richards by the european
commission itself has reported that
there is an association between the
presence of migrants from outside of the
eu in a respective anti-eu vote
obviously the anti-eu sentiment can be
mediated by the skill level of the
migrant but it does put the european
union in a potentially uncomfortable
scenario reduce some of the pressure on
its social programs by bringing in an
external labor force but risk
anti-establishment sentiment
in 2019 victor orban unveiled his family
protection action plan which would give
potentially thousands of euros to women
who give birth to enough children
offering 30 000 euros of interest-free
loans that would be canceled upon the
birth of a woman's third child although
seemingly popular among orban supporters
and also weirdly among conservative
pundits in the united states just
injecting money and hoping to produce
babies is more difficult than it seems
and will probably take a while before we
see any long-term impact assuming that
these policies will make a significant
dent there's also an important question
about which one comes first
interest-free loans of 30 000 are by no
means cheap so can they work in time to
offset the additional costs an
increasingly older population will
produce to find an answer to that
question is a matter of time the reason
why europe may face a larger problem
with its dependency ratio than a country
like the united states besides the fact
that the us is younger generally is that
the eu's legitimacy is still more
precarious as a political institution
the eu schengen area made it possible
for europeans to move between borders
and is seen as an overall net positive
but the ability for europeans to move
freely between borders may also
exasperate pressures on the countries
that are facing an increasingly older
population rural regions continue to
decline in population while urban
regions continue to grow and this
phenomenon does not just happen within
countries but more importantly
concerning the stability of the entire
european union it happens between
countries within europe as there is an
outward migration of younger people to
urban centers due to better economic
opportunities central and eastern
european countries will continue to face
even more demographic pressure that can
weaken their economic growth and social
support systems and when that happens
enough for a long enough time that
people get increasingly concerned about
their younger neighbors leaving for
better economic opportunities elsewhere
the ramifications for the political
institution that seems like it is
accelerating that process can be huge
[Music]
you